Now we're going to talk about the question why assertions?
What are assertions really buying us?
This boils down to three or four basic reasons.
First, assertions make code self-checking.
That is, they make the code that write fail proactively when somethings wrong,
and this can lead to more effective testing.
Second, assertions make code fail early at a location that is closer to the actual bug,
since this is more relevant to debugging than to testing,
but it's generally the case that debugging is a different backwards problem
where you're reasoning in a backwards sort of way
about the behavior of the software that you wrote,
and the fewer steps there are in one of these backwards chains, the better.
Assertions really can help with that.
Third, assertions can help us assign blame.
It's often the case that assertions live at interfaces between different modules,
and in many cases it's possible to look at where the bad values came from
that lead to the assertion failure and use that information to assign blame
to one of the modules involved in the call or to the other one.
Real software testing exercises often lead to different finger-pointing problems,
and any tools that we have that allow us to accurately assign blame
to one or the other of our software modules can be valuable.
The final reason we like assertions
is because they allow us to create executable documentation
about assumptions we've made, about preconditions in our code,
and so by writing down executable checks on our preconditions,
we not only get to check these preconditions when the code runs,
but also we're documenting for other developers
the things that need to be true for that code to execute correctly.
Post conditions are things that are supposed to be true after our code runs.
Again, in addition to creating executable checks for these,
we're also telling other developers what we think should be true.
This should allow other people to rely on this postconditions.
Invariants are closely related to preconditions and postconditions.
These are things that need to be true, for example,
at every iteration of a loop.